when the 2018 iPad pro was released the
most disappointing thing about it was a
software but yesterday Apple announced
iPad OS a new operating system that
allows iPads to be more like computers
it's coming this September and it
supports every iPad since the iPad air 2
first of all there's a new homescreen
that holds six columns of apps instead
of five currently on iOS 12 and they can
all slide over to the side to make room
for the new today view with customizable
widgets all on one page iOS 13's dark
mode is also coming to iPad OS it turns
on easily from the control center and it
works system-wide Apple is also making
it super easy for third-party apps to
support it with their new switch UI
framework face ID on the iPad pro will
and lock up to 30% faster and apps will
be smaller in size so they'll download
faster and launch up to two times faster
than before the Photos app gets a new
Photos tab which organizes your photos
in new day month and year views we also
finally have some awesome photo editing
tools allowing you to adjust things like
brightness contrast saturation and white
balance you get those same tools for
video editing as well alongside auto
enhance crop and rotate yes you can
finally rotate videos with iPad OS
Safari automatically chooses the desktop
version of web sites and it
automatically optimizes it for touch
there's also a brand new download
manager that saves downloads right into
the new downloads folder
within the files app making it much more
like an actual computer and speaking of
the files app it's now actually decent
in more computer-like than ever before
by finally allowing you to connect an
external hard drive SD card or USB flash
drive in transfer files the biggest deal
is the new on my ipad location which
allows you to create folders and
transfer files directly to those folders
without having to first import them to
camera roll or put them on the iCloud
drive so it's basically like a Mac OS
file manager you can even zip in unzip
files and folders another big step up is
that you can now connect a digital
camera and import files directly into
apps like Lightroom without having to
copy them to camera roll first like we
had to do before
or for cloud storage you can now share
files and entire folders with other
people and we even get support for
shared servers so if you have a cloud
accessible Nass you can access those
files right on your iPad and finally
there's a new column view that makes it
easy to navigate through folders in a
preview pane that gives you detailed
metadata with quick actions like markup
rotate and create PDF Apple has also
taken the iPad a step further by adding
the same keyboard shortcuts we get on
Mac OS right onto the iPad using the
smart keyboard or any compatible
Bluetooth keyboard you can now also
download custom fonts right from the app
store and manage them on your iPad the
most annoying thing while browsing the
web is having to create new accounts and
passwords
well now Apple is adding a new sign-in
with Apple feature that automatically
and instantly creates accounts using
your existing Apple ID with a simple
face ID or touch ID confirmation and
there's even an option to create a
unique fake email address that forwards
to your real email so it adds tons of
security as well the iPad can also be
used to encrypt your home kits security
cameras footage so you know that no one
else is able to hack in and view your
cameras feed Apple has also completely
redesigned the text editing with brand
new gestures that are so much easier to
understand and use to move the cursor
while editing just touch and drag it to
your desired location to select a block
of text just drag your finger over it
you can also select text using multiple
taps two taps for a word three for a
sentence in four taps for an entire
paragraph one selected
pinch with three fingers to copy then
spread with three fingers to paste and
there's no more need to shake your iPad
to undo now simply swipe with three
fingers instead Apple has also added new
on-screen keyboard features like the new
quick path or swipe keyboard in the
ability to pinch and shrink the keyboard
to detach it and move it wherever you
want for one-handed typing now on to
multitasking Apple has added some
additional options to easily switch
between the app that's open in slide
over mode simply swipe up on the bar on
the bottom of the app and every previous
app you've had open pops up you can even
slide along the bar to swipe with tweens
slide over apps just like you can do on
the home bar for full screen apps
another huge update that makes the iPad
more like a Mac is the ability to open
multiple windows of the same app so that
means two notes apps to mail apps or
even two third party apps like Microsoft
Word side-by-side this also means that
you can have multiple split-screen
spaces open with multiple instances of
the same apps running at the same time
and to view those spaces just tap on an
app on the dock and it'll show you all
the spaces that include that out Apple
has also made it easier to work with the
Apple pencil with a new easy way to mark
up a photo or page just drag your Apple
pencil from the corner of the screen to
mark up and there's also an awesome new
full-page option which actually includes
the whole full length page reviewing not
just the section that was visible when
you started the markup within markup
there's a new pencil tool palette with
updated icons you can easily shrink or
drag and move the palette anywhere you'd
like so it doesn't get in your way
now here's an outstanding new feature
called sidecar you can now use your iPad
as a secondary Mac display allowing you
to view an app on the iPad while working
on your Mac or exactly the opposite you
can actually use your iPad to draw
design edit or create content using full
desktop Mac apps while viewing the
finished result on your Mac and it even
works wirelessly alongside all those
awesome changes to the iPad Apple has a
massive list of changes that are coming
with iPad OS and I'll share that link in
the video description below but here are
some of the coolest changes the iPad now
supports the ps4 in Xbox one s gaming
controller the 2018 iPad pro now
supports dolby atmos playback you can
now select Wi-Fi networks and Bluetooth
accessories straight from the control
center you can now add attachments to
events in calendar maps is completely
redesigned to include more detail Siri
has a brand new voice you can now
control your entire iPad using a new
voice control feature and there's just
so much more than that so if this video
helped you out make sure to tap that
like button and click that button above
to subscribe thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video and the
protist and
and like the Mac Pro they'll all be
available in this in the fall